[Music]
nestled in the side of the euro
mountains the site of reversible destiny
in japan is an experienced park where
guests encounter the unexpected
the park was designed by artists shusaku
arakawa and madeline jinns and consists
of sculptures pavilions and constantly
changing terrains
there is an intricate network of
paths and 24 types of plants that
emphasize the changing of the season
such as cherry blossoms in the
springtime and vibrant autumn leaves in
the fall
some of the attractions include the
critical resemblance house which has a
map of gifu prefecture a region of
central japan as a rooftop
and the reversible destiny office that
contains an uneven pastel colored maze
and a ceiling that mirrors the design of
the floor
visitors are encouraged to explore the
site with the mindset of a child
to climb be curious and discover
different visual perceptions
but because of slanting angles steep
hills and narrow pathways the site of
reversible destiny offers optional
helmets to ensure a safe excursion
[Music]
you